this is eight news now Weekend Edition
live local now the family of a man
stabbed to death is breaking their
silence thanks for joining us tonight at
six o'clock I'm Sasha Loftis the family
of Marco Hornsby is upset about how the
case of their son's death is playing out
in the criminal justice system 8 news
now reporter Joshua peguero spoke with
them tonight
records show Jeremy Garrett to complete
deal last month in the death of Marco
Hornsby a deal that hornsby's family is
upset about I feel I was cheated I have
been cheated not just me even the
community because this this person if he
does it the everybody is going to start
doing the same thing trying to learn how
to beat the system to get back out
Howard Hornsby describes his son Marco
as a father of four who loved his
children on May 8th he would have turned
39 instead of a day of Celebration his
family is preparing for pain I can't
call him some happy birthday or nothing
so every days get harder but we will get
Justice first We're not gonna let this
go Garrett was arrested on January 9th
for open murder police say the crime
happened on November 23rd at an
apartment near Maryland Parkway and
Bonanza Road his family says Marco was
stabbed more than 20 times police say
Garrett and Marco were fighting right
before the stabbing but a nagging
question that pestered the Hornsby
family is why did it turn deadly that's
all I know is why
if you if you can't fight then it's okay
walk away you want to take another man's
life he's in there walk away you can't
beat him walk away why can't you walk
away record show Jeremy Garrett is
scheduled to be sentenced on Tuesday at
9 A.M reporting at the Regional Justice
Center Joshua piguero eight news now